well when i was when i was growing up i
played in hardcore bands hardcore punk
bands and I was a little suburban
teenage punk rocker and one of my
favorite bands was the sex pistols but
by the time I got into the Sex Pistols
they had been broken up for a long time
and then they did a reunion tour and I
went to go see the reunion tour and it
was it was so disconcerting because
here's a band who had broken up long
before I became interested in punk rock
and then I was standing watching them on
stage and it was flawless like the music
sounded great and Johnny Rotten AK
Johnny Lydon was just this amazing front
person and then afterwards we all went
out and got really drunk so that
experience of like seeing your heroes
who you thought were dead and it turns
out they're not dead they're live and in
the flesh and then afterwards going out
and drinking cheap beer with them that
was a good one
my goals when I was growing up we're
almost non-existent you know my biggest
goal as a musician was to maybe at some
point play a show in New York City
didn't matter if anyone showed up it
didn't matter if it was a big venue or
small venue just to be able to say that
I played a concert in New York City or
to have DJed in New York City and maybe
if I was really really lucky to at some
point go to Europe and do a DJ gig
beyond that I didn't really have any
goals maybe it's the product of growing
up really poor but I also when I was
growing up most of my most of the
musicians who were my heroes were people
who never achieved much commercially in
terms of success so I never thought of
commercial success as being something
worthy of pursuing so very simply I just
want to make music and maybe if I was
really lucky play a concert in New York
City
my only goal as a musician is to try and
make music that I love and I know that
might sound reduction is not really
simple but that's pretty much it I mean
commercial success it's interesting you
know having commercial successes and
it's interesting to be part of that
process especially because we live in a
culture that's so fame-obsessed so it's
interesting to see it from both sides
but for me the only virtue or the only
value that commercial success has is it
enables you to have an audience for your
music and so for me commercial success
is like a strategy to try and get more
people to actually listen to the music
like commercial success is not a end in
and of itself
yeah I'm not very good at chillin or
resting or relaxing or taking a moment
where and I don't work so as I'm
finishing one album I'm thinking of the
other four albums I'd like to make and
you know myriad other projects I'd like
to be working on so I mean I sort of
envy the more well-adjusted musicians or
writers or filmmakers who when they
finish one project like they take a
month off and go to Bali and sit on a
beach I think that's really healthy you
know to give your brain and your body a
rest but no unfortunately even as i'm
finishing something i'm already working
on the next few things